one common question that gets asked
perennially particularly in discussion
groups about stoicism has to do with its
compatibility with another
philosophical approach perspective
movement school however you want to call
it and that's existentialism is stoicism
compatible with
existentialism and there is a very
simple answer to this but uh
unsatisfying one yes
everything is compatible with everything
to some extent so in a very trivial way
yes stoicism is compatible with
existentialism
but we have to think about well what
does it mean to be compatible by that
you
have you know some sort of model in mind
like one bit of software being
compatible with another bit of software
meaning that they don't interfere with
each other
and they have their separate areas that
they work with stoicism and anything
else any other kind of life philosophy
are not going to be compatible in that
way because they do extend to
all sorts of matters our personal
identity our responsibility our choices
how we relate to other people
understanding human culture and society
the larger cosmos you see that this is
not that sort of compatibility so then
you can say well how would they in fact
be compatible maybe they have similar
doctrines on some things you can say
they're on the same page
or maybe they provide nice overlaps
where they
complement each other where one doesn't
have something the other one can
fill that in or we might think of other
types of compatibility you know even as
just as weak as not contradicting each
other
but
compatibility is a relative term
so we can say
stoicism and existentialism are
compatible
dot dot dot dot dot insofar as and then
we start looking at things a little bit
more closely and we find out where they
are indeed compatible and where
you have to say well i'm going to take
one of these but not the other one
because i can't have
both
interestingly that's one of the things
that both stoic philosophers and
existentialist philosophers thematize so
that very dynamic right there is
something that they do share in common
now when it comes to existentialism we
have to be a bit more careful than we
would with other
you know life philosophies like say
conscientism where it's closely
identified with a manual count or even
hegelianism
existentialism doesn't name a single
philosopher
or even a single approach or even a
single set of beliefs and assertions
rather it is a complex rich and
sometimes contradictory
set of thinkers topics texts oftentimes
in communication with each other and
responding to sometimes criticizing each
other even ones that are as close as
sartre and de bouvoir will differ on
some matters so you can't just say yes
existentialism is the doctrine that xyz
because not all the existentialists
agree
on that instead there's
overlapping
themes
you should be particularly careful of
relying upon jean-paul sartre who many
people take as articulating the
existentialist doctrine because sartre
asserts that he's defining
existentialism it's important to point
out
that many other existentialists disagree
with certain many of the things that he
says
including his life partner and in some
respects uh corrector
simone de bouvoir when it comes to
certain doctrines about existentialism
so be on your guard about that
you know who count in the existentialist
spectrum well we have the you know the
big three that we often talk about from
the 19th century surin kierkegaard
friedrich nietzsche
feodor dostoevsky but there's many other
figures in that time that get placed in
there including ibsen tolstoy to some
extent
you know check off and you notice it's
not a french thing particularly at the
start
and then it goes on and we include
people like miguel de una muno in spain
and
leo stuff originally in russia moving to
france after the russian revolution they
are existentialists as is uh carl
jospers and
martin heidegger all of these people
figure into that
that field even in the french field we
have not just jean-paul sartre and of
course we mentioned simone de bouvoir we
have gabriel marcel the first person to
use the term existentialism in french
and uh you know other russians like
berjayev who came so existentialism is
not a single monolithic doctrine i'll
mention as well that stoicism while it
has a much greater internal consistency
is not a monolithic doctrine either as
seneca points out we do not have kings
as stoics right so there's variance in
how stoicism itself can be interpreted
so this is very important there's
another thing that i need to to point
out as well
which is that when you see references to
the stoics usually written with a lower
case s in existentialist literature
it will very often not be actual
stoicism
uppercase s the real philosophy that's
out there
partially embodied in you know seneca
and marcus aurelius and epictetus and
musonius rufus and heracles and then
also you know talked about in many other
authors works it's not that it's kind of
a caricature
of stoicism that was popular from about
the 19th century all the way deep into
the 20th century where stoicism is
essentially
you know the dichotomy of control and a
few other things withdrawing from the
world so that you can be happy and not
getting it too involved in things
outside of yourself and repressing
emotions which we know is not genuine
stoicism so two things that we've
pointed out already now let's talk about
where existentialism and stoicism are
indeed compatible with each other so
there's a number of different things
that we can rattle off and you can
explore these on your own
really central the freedom that a human
being has to choose not just between
different alternatives do this don't do
this
not just between prioritizations this is
more important than this
but to choose
who one is what kind of person one is
going to be to determine oneself through
the
limited freedom that we have within
situations in which we do make choices
another very important thing the
importance of affectivity i mentioned
emotions just earlier the stoics think
it's very important to understand our
emotions the existentialists think it's
very important to analyze and understand
and and make sense out of what our
emotions are telling us so there's a lot
of compatibility
there
choosing for oneself rather than trying
to choose for everybody all at once and
dominate them another key theme
the stoics don't think that you don't
have any connections to other people and
that you should behave as best you can
like a model person but they understand
that that's not going to necessarily
influence others even socrates as
epictetus says only succeeded maybe one
time out of a thousand with the people
he was talking with similarly for
existentialism uh you realize that you
do in fact try to choose for the whole
world but nobody else has to follow you
and this is where john pulsart
actually can be helpful he calls that
despair this realization that when you
act you're acting basically just for
that little bit of the universe that is
your
self um living in and learning from
concrete human situations very important
for both
and tied in with this having to figure
things out experientially it's not just
a matter of like getting a stoic or
existentialist checklist and doing the
exercises and now everything falls into
place or getting the right books and
reading them
there's a back and forth dynamic and
dialectic with you and the rest of the
universe
the little portions that you're engaged
with trying to learn from actually doing
things and then the
responsibility that one bears for
oneself for overcoming
ignorance or deception or you know
breaking out of bad uses of our human
freedom
very important in both stoicism and
existentialism now there are some
important differences you know the
stoics do have
a classic literature and a present
literature that you can draw upon the
existentialists you know 19th and 20th
century there are some present day
existentialists as well so different
works right which are not always on
exactly the same page
the stoics do have a substantive
conception of human nature and you know
of morality that existentialists would
be a little bit more leery about relying
upon although there's nothing to keep
you as an existentialist from saying
well i think the stoics actually got it
right i'm going to commit to this and
then finally you know for the stoics for
classic stoics and the their
representatives in the present that we
often call traditional stoics there are
a few things that most existentialists
are just simply not going to buy into
you know that have to do with cosmology
the notion of there being a you know
stoic kind of god which is similar to
some respects to deism
um
god is not outside of the universe but
rather you know
the universe as a totality so a
pantheism
the universe itself is ordered
rationally providentially for the good
existentialists are pretty much going to
reject that but then again so do many
modern stoics so that's not that big of
an area of incompatibility unless
somebody makes it to be so so as you can
see the answer to this question is a
little bit more complicated
than yes or no it depends on a number of
factors
you